[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE BASICH: Thanks
for having me here.
I'm really excited to be
here today to spend an hour
or so talking and share
my perspective, which
is my main sharing [INAUDIBLE]
what I want to do today
is share my perspective
of what I've
done with my life and
the level of risk.
So much I've learned
through my childhood, which
I've lived kind of
a unique childhood
with epilepsy, which has been
kind of from five years old
till about 13.
And of course, one
of those unexpected
journeys that 20 years later I
realize the tools it gave me.
And why I say that is I gained
a different perspective.
I owe this a lot to
my mom and my dad
for putting in front of
me different options.
And those were things that more
were about exercising the mind,
trying to fight
epilepsy, which is
a joining of both
sides of the brain
together, firing seizures.
So in the beginning
of that journey,
I did a lot of mental drawings,
little different doctors
of putting puzzles together,
trying to use a focus.
And what it came
down to was actually
a food diet and snowboarding,
which I owe a lot
to my healing of epilepsy.
This took about three years
of a certain kind of diet.
And snowboarding, I
kind of use that word
as a healing tool for me because
it was a big focus for me.
It's something I felt like
I was grounded in the world.
And this is in the mid '80s.
And I don't know if you know
a lot about snowboarding
in the '80s and into the '90s,
it was not a welcome sport.
And so that was
kind of, in a way,
a perfect fit because I didn't
fit in any way in school.
And so my journey
with all of this--
again, kind of what
I owe to my parents
is the OK of being different.
And those things
is the things I've
learned 20 years later on
why my career in snowboarding
went the way it did and why I
did the things that I do now,
which is a lot about
just feeling in action,
doing things, seeing
where it goes,
what resonates inside
to self growth.
And in snowboarding, it
kind of put me in a spot
where I kind of followed for
a while the World Tour, World
Cup, did the competition.
We were all developing
the sport together,
so we kind of shaped
how things were run.
But after about 20
years later I realized
I was kind of growing out
of the competition scene.
And with my childhood
of just trying
to take on different
things different ways,
I saw a different
perspective in snowboarding
that wasn't developed yet.
I was photographed a
lot in snowboarding.
I had a lot of ideas at the same
time how to be photographed.
Working with two different
minds to create an image
can be very
challenging sometimes,
especially when you're the
one on risk with your life
and feeling the power of passion
for what you're actually doing.
And so I've slowly started to
develop these different parts
of cameras, joining.
I hired someone to do some
soldering for some wires
and I've started
taking self portraits.
This is in the late '90s.
And I realized this was a huge
room, a space to figure out
what else could come to.
And at the time my career, I
was getting at an age where
snowboarding didn't really want
to sponsor someone in their mid
20s to compete because the 19-,
15-year-old is going to beat me
out.
So it was up to me, if I
wanted to stay in snowboarding,
to recreate myself, reinvent
who I was in the sport.
And so the self-portrait
world became my focus
and gave me a whole other
15 years as a career.
I'm 45 years old now.
I still have sponsors as a
snowboarding professional,
and it's really
based on creativity.
And that space of
creativity has changed
over the 15 years I've
been doing self portraits,
a lot because of technology
has come into the game
in different ways.
Back in when I started, I had
about a 40-pound backpack.
You'd have to hike
everything twice
to get the shot
because you'd have
to hike, set the camera up,
and then ride and go back
into your camera.
So one photo could take weeks.
Now we have GoPro cameras,
different smaller cameras
that you can do
something very quick.
And when that
happened, I realized
I want to keep progressing
with self portraits.
And so I worked
with a paraglider.
I bought a motorized
paraglider, and wanting
to capture something
that was storming up
in my mind of
different perspective.
And it wasn't until
10 years later
after that that I actually
got to do another image that
brought something
new to me, which
was kind of following
like a bird, which is now
the drone world.
And I wanted to
show a little bit
of a little one-minute
video of my first 10 years
of shooting self portraits.
And this is mostly--
well, this is all with a
ASLR, about a 15-pound camera.
And enjoy this for a minute.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Winter we've had for the
nine years I lived there,
so a lot of fun.
But after the winter,
I was kind of like, ah,
I want to really capture what
I'm seeing in snowboarding,
what I'm feeling.
So I went and spent
$600 on remotes.
I didn't know a lot
about photography,
but I had this first
photo I wanted to capture.
Took me actually about
five weeks to do it.
I ended up failing and
trying it again, really
wanting to capture what
snowboarding was to me on film
and think I could
actually share it
with my family and the industry.
That's how I started
taking self portraits.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The helicopter drop--
it was a couple of
year project of where
I wanted to really capture a
photo that looked impossible.
The whole idea was
to shoot the shot
and not have the
helicopter in the frame.
And so it needed to
be big and Alaska
was the best spot to do it.
I drove all the way up there
pretty much just to do that.
So once I left the helicopter,
I realized I'm never
going to experience this again.
It's like that in
between a flying squirrel
and a drop in a cliff.
But after a couple of people
saw the photo afterwards,
I started to realize
maybe snowboarding
isn't ready for this or it's
not really snowboarding.
I'm on a snowboard,
but it was more
on the artistic
side of just wanting
to create something
different, unique.
And so that's how it got shaped.
It turned out great.
I was stoked.
Unfortunately, no one really
ran it the way I wanted to,
but oh, well.
I got it on my wall.
[END PLAYBACK]
MIKE BASICH: So that's the first
10 years of my self portrait
career.
And one of the biggest things
I wanted to share about it
as well as the challenge to
make a company invest in me.
It's a never ending story.
Even after 15 years of
shooting self portraits,
I came to one of my sponsors
a time, which was GoPro,
and said, I got an
idea I want to do.
I want to ride with adrenaline
and release it halfway
down the mountain.
And it took me six
months to convince them.
I didn't actually
convince them I
forced them, in
a way, which I've
learned to use the media how to
leak stuff out and put people
in the spot that they feel
like they should invest.
And this was one of them,
which was pretty interesting.
It worked out.
They actually made a worldwide
TV commercial out of it.
But again, it's one of the
hard things as an individual
to come to a huge company
and say, this is my idea.
I don't know how it's
going to turn out,
but just can you believe in me?
And that's been probably
the hardest thing
to pave the way in snowboarding
for a 45-year-old athlete
to continue in the industry.
And the level risk is kind
of what I mentioned earlier,
which a lot of the reason
why this worked was I
was kind of the only one
who was willing to risk
$5,000 in camera
equipment in the air.
I had the athletic
ability to ride,
but it was also really about
two things coming together
that no one else
was willing to do.
And I would lean on that
a lot because that's
kind of how I see a lot
of things happen my life.
Even today my lifestyle, living
off the grid, which I do,
is a collision of what
I can have access to
and what I personally
want to do with my life.
So there's the TV
commercial I wanted
to show you as well, this
releasing moment of a camera,
which is one of the reasons
I bought that motorized
paraglider.
I wanted to capture
this moving out
of the perspective of the body.
And so here we are a
good 12 years later on,
making that actually
a reality for me,
which has been very fun.
Here it is on YouTube.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Wherever the home is,
you can't get homesick.
It's really that simple.
[END PLAYBACK]
MIKE BASICH: So that
was another project
that took a lot
of fighting to do,
which I don't know if
it's interesting at all,
but it was a very
big moment for me
in my photography
and content world.
It's kind of what my
job is these days.
I come up creative
ideas, try to figure out
how to do something new
and supply it to a company
to market it or create new
devices that kind of fit
that idea better.
And there's one other one that
I think I'd like to show you,
that I think you would
actually have seen it here
because what I've been told this
device GoPro and Google brought
to market a few
years after this.
So please share your thoughts.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- At any moment
when you're riding,
you can just freeze the moment
and move around anywhere
you want to go.
Continue, stop.
The objects of these cameras
mounted the way I did
was just giving you the
freedom to edit at any angle.
Built some plywood,
little handle.
I got 13 cameras, which once
you get them all recording,
there is no way to register
them all, which the way
I did it was pretty old school,
just to build the time card.
And this one is round.
Once you get it
going, recording,
move it at the same time,
that's your registration point.
Same time, so you can go two
minutes and three seconds
on each shot and find the
same moment and move around,
and then continue with
one going a certain way.
Stop, go around.
and just to share more
of the 360-degree feeling
you get when you're
snowboarding or doing anything.
Just the eyes are
such a beautiful tool
to receive stuff.
[END PLAYBACK]
MIKE BASICH: So
that's kind of where
I'm standing with my career
as far as a photographer
and an athlete.
And I've recently have
brought in my lifetime passion
of working with my
hands, woodworking,
and trying to value life.
That's one of the
main things I'm
trying to learn how to do
every day by getting my hands
dirty, kind of trying to
learn the things that I
use in my life and
try to do it myself.
So I've chosen to
live off the grid.
I live in a
300-square-foot cabin
on 40 acres off about three
miles off any power grid.
And I've been learning
the way of raising
my consciousness on how I move
in the world and what I use.
And I wanted to share a
different perspective that
isn't exactly pretty.
The more I know,
the harder it gets.
And I know you guys are here
a lot to supply information.
And it's interesting
to strive to know more,
to want to have a closer
connection to the world of what
happens.
And that's my continuous goal.
And I'm kind of wanting also
to have a conversation with you
all on how to manage, how
to balance information
because I've gone in
waves of having too much,
not knowing how to
do with it because I
feel responsible for
what I'm learning.
And that's something
that I've tried
to figure out how to teach.
I've taught at some
schools, and the best
I can know to do with
all this information
is to do it in action.
And then once you put
something into action,
you have another feeling
that can overtake
the mind of just information.
And that has to do a lot
with the heart, whatever
it's resonated in you.
Not everything does
that I do, so I
don't have a strong
connection with it
and I'll move on to
something that is.
And what I've
learned why that is,
at least from my perspective,
is that we're all
born with something first.
The first organ that's
formed is the heart.
That's kind of what takes place.
It's our main seed.
And that was the
one thing that I
keep going back to for all my
answers that I can't answer.
And that's the one
thing somewhere
in me is knowing
what to do with it
and back to resonating by
doing something in action.
And I'd love to talk to you
all about what resonates.
I know snowboarding has for me.
Living off the grid, being
closer to the indigenous
needs of what we
need to live life.
I don't expect myself or
everyone to do everything
that we need to do because
that's the beauty of working
together to do something.
And I mean that in a way where
I've learned to hike my water
miles just to brush my teeth.
And then you can
imagine if you do
that, you have some
sort of exhilaration
like you just ran a marathon
and all you have to do
is brush your
teeth to feel that.
And that is simply being more
connected with what we do,
what we use.
And again, it's not
the same for everybody.
It's really what
resonates in the heart
because that's kind
of, really, that's
all we have to lean back on.
At least that's my perspective.
And so I wanted to
show another video
of my other part
of my life outside
of the snowboard
career, of where
my heart resonates the most
and what that looks like over--
it's been about 15 years now
putting that more and more
to action.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- It wasn't till I
was 33 that I finally
felt it was time to
bring this childhood
dream to life of building my
own house my own two hands.
Came across these beautiful
40 acres in Donner summit.
When I first saw
it, I was like, this
is the beginning of my dream.
It's buried.
Which that winter was a
huge winter in the snow.
I got to experience
a place with a teepee
and get a feeling for the area.
Finishing my winter off
in Alaska, I was like,
what kind of shape
does this house
that I'm going to build, this
dream, what kind of shape
does it have?
And with most things,
you've got to really let
go of all your ideas,
close your eyes,
and like, what's
this really about?
And I started to realize
it was about me, my heart.
And it was like, where does
this experience of feeling
most alive--
where does this live?
I started to realize this was
standing on a mountain peak.
This is where, in
the past 33 years,
this is where I've
felt most alive.
I started looking at all these
photos and I'm like, wow.
There's a shape to this feeling,
standing on a mountain peak
and reaching out to the world.
This is the start of
an idea, off a feeling.
And I think everyone
can relate this feeling.
It's just where you're high
on life and feel most alive.
Like, everyone has
that certain structure,
just reaching out as well,
keeping your feet grounded.
And from there on, it just
started to take shape.
I'm like, oh, I've
got to draw this down.
And soon as I knew
it, I was experiencing
something that's been
experienced for hundreds
and hundreds of years.
You see this drawing of a star
connecting to all your dots
on your body.
And if you connect
them the other way,
it becomes a pentagon.
So I think if you
go off of instinct
or you go off the
golden ratio, you're
going to end up
with the same thing.
Of course, you have to
really let go and listen
to that heartbeat.
Go where, where does that
heartbeat feel most alive?
For me it was staying
on the mountain, where
I realized that's what I want
my house to be because that's
where I felt most alive.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- The great thing about taking
on a project in this way
is that everything naturally
happens afterwards.
Where your feet are is where
the front door should be.
Where your arm's reaching out
is where your window should be.
The hardest part has been
dealing with the weather,
mixing cement in the snow.
But it's really what I
wanted is to put myself
in a place I got back to
the basics of simple living.
Living off the grid
has been something
that's always wanted to do.
And looking around with what
I had to work with was I
had a lot of rocks.
That's what really
survived up here.
And so my house became
built out of rock.
I had no idea it's
going to take me
four years to build
my house, but it
was one of those
projects and again, it's
the way for me to find
out and express who I was.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
MIKE BASICH: So
that was my project
of finding my
place in the world.
And what I've learned, which
the biggest part I learned
about that project was time.
Imagine being by
yourself in the woods.
You work with time,
especially when it's snowing.
And I realized that's
a lot to do with motion
and back onto the golden ratio.
I don't know if a lot about
the golden ratio, but it's
the basics of quantum
physics, how we all built--
everything else is kind
of built under that
unless you go outside of that
equation, which we all do.
But what I truly--
back to the heart
has a natural instinct that
is based on the golden ratio,
that I feel like is a great
balance to find out the stuff
I'm struggling with,
as I was sharing.
Like sometimes there's too much.
Sometimes there's too little.
And those are kind
of, I think, has a lot
to do with being too much in the
past, too much in the future,
or too much in the present.
And so what I've learned,
back into the golden ratio,
is to find things in thirds.
You have the past,
present, and the future.
The future we don't know.
We have a way of
shaping that together.
The past has already happened,
so we know what has been.
And the present is of
right now, the simpleness
of doing something that will
no longer be this moment.
We can record it, pass it
on, which becomes the past.
And so that is a way that I've
learned to stay in balance,
to stay in health, and to
continue to trust the instinct.
Because as I get older,
I have more layers.
I have more
experiences, more things
to fight through
to figure out what
is actually happening in here.
And every time I talk
to someone that they
don't know what they're doing
or what to do, I relied--
go back to your childhood
when you had less layers.
It's much more clear.
It's much more simple.
And it's most of
the time very true.
Whatever you were
dreaming as a child,
there's something in there
that is wanting to do that.
And that's my perspective today
I'm wanting to bring to you.
Don't forget about
the child in you
because it is very important.
It has an important
message and something
very important to share.
Thank you for having me today.
[APPLAUSE]
And if anyone has any questions
about anything, please--
I'm here.
And I brought some books
of my self-portrait career
as well that has some
other images in it that
have a uniqueness to it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] house, do
you have other people around?
Or don't you miss connection
with your friends?
I mean, you probably have a
connection with, let's say,
nature.
But I would miss the
daily contact with people.
MIKE BASICH: Yeah,
it's different.
I have a different
connection with people now.
I have, in a way, the
same amount of people
visiting me that I did
when I was in the suburbs.
I lived in a huge house before
this and people are seemed
always excited to do
something a little unique,
and so I get people
wanting to do something
off the beaten trail, snowshoe
up or mountain bike up.
And it becomes more
unique of a connection,
which I've found some of the
space because it's very quiet.
It's very holding of
the space together.
And a lot of times, what they
experienced to get to the place
woken them up in a
certain way that they're
ready for a certain experience
of conversation or sharing.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted
to ask, what are you
trying in the next
10 years or 20 years?
Do you find people in
snowboarding and photographing
yourself or photographing
other riders?
Or what do you see [INAUDIBLE]?
MIKE BASICH: It's
a great question.
I truly don't have the
true answer to that.
I do love photography.
I think, in a way, it will be a
combination of more my building
world and sharing that
maybe with younger crowds.
I'm about to be a father and
so my excitement to share
is accelerating as a day goes
by to get ready for that.
And however may be--
content's a great way
to share information.
But I I've learned
giving talks is
something I enjoy and
seem to have a closer
connection of
understanding how to talk
to some someone
versus making a video.
So I'd say more talks like this.
AUDIENCE: So living off the
grid and living in the woods
as such, you might have
encountered certain situations
where the things
are very extreme,
in terms of nature or
wildlife or anything.
Any interesting
experience that you had?
Like, where you
felt you've not been
prepared for what
you were encountering
at that time [INAUDIBLE]?
MIKE BASICH: Yes.
Many things I realized
I wasn't prepared.
I live off the grid enough where
I can hike back to civilization
within a day.
And so that's my security of
not doing something right.
But I I've learned a lot about
how to shop because everything
I do I have to get rid of--
my trash, human waste.
Everything you have to
deal with, carry water.
Water freezing is
a huge task where
I'm at because there's
a lot of rocks.
I can't bury water below
freezing very easily.
When I do, it's very
limited water amount.
And so I've become
great appreciation
in water and working
with the temperatures.
I welded a lot, and
that was actually
like a saver of welding
to keep my hands warm
while I was out in the snow.
AUDIENCE: You've also
mentioned at some point risk,
taking it and handling it.
I would like-- you've obviously
done lots of things that
for most of us feel very risky.
How have you balanced taking
risks and, well, living to be
here, giving this talk today?
MIKE BASICH: The level of risk
I've managed with what I know
and also what I don't know.
I don't have all the
equations figured out
before something happens.
And so that's a level of
risk what I'm willing to do,
the one I'm willing to take.
A lot of them, I try not to do
where my life is threatened.
But snowboarding has taught me
how to perform under pressure
because life's on the line.
You screw up, you can get
seriously hurt or die.
And to do that at a
multifunction of shooting
remotes at the same
time, I've developed
awareness of different things.
So if I'm building my cabin
out in the woods on a ladder,
I can feel the space.
I feel a lot better and
I can manage my ability
what I'm doing.
The level of risk
that I enjoy taking
is being vulnerable,
criss-crossing
the threshold of discomfort.
And I do that with
athletic ability,
but I like also doing that in a
way of just taking on something
I don't know.
And I did that my whole life.
That's how I learned how
to do things in the world.
I never went to college.
I own a snowboard
outerwear company in Japan.
I've dealt with all my
contracts in snowboarding,
never had an agent.
And so I've just taken on
things where the level of risk
feels high, but I'm
willing to fail.
And that's one of my key
understandings on risk.
If you're willing to
fail, you can always
gain something from it because
I've failed many times.
I always do.
It's something that
I'm expected to do.
And people forget
that, I realize,
especially when I
get someone coming
wanting to build a tiny home.
They have these prints
of, like, all these plans
they've been planning
out for years
and they've never
picked up a hammer
yet because they're scared
something's going to go wrong.
And I try to encourage
people the level of risk,
of it being known as failure.
It's kind of like,
give it a shot.
If you need to do
it on a small level,
do that, and just learn
from the failing process
because those have the answers.
And it's not going to be an
answer that you're looking for.
It's going to be something
that you're not expecting.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to
ask you of the moment
when you jump up to
the helicopter, what
do you think that
[INAUDIBLE] more concerned
about the jump itself?
Or maybe about the picture?
Or [INAUDIBLE]?
MIKE BASICH: That
photo, the helicopter,
was a unique one for me.
My biggest issue at the
moment before I jumped
was a down pressure of the
blades of the helicopter.
So I actually got going
faster than gravity.
I could barely lift my
board off this skid.
I just kind of slid off.
And around that time, I totally
forgot about the remote,
that I was shooting photos.
And there's a
certain process when
that's happened because
when I grab my snowboard,
the other hand naturally
wants to do the same.
And so I had no idea
if I took the photo.
This is back in the
slide film days,
so I just knew the camera
took the whole roll.
And I was lucky enough
to get a photo of it
because I put
myself in a position
where I didn't want the
pressure from other film
and photographers.
So I was the only one
there taking a photo.
And it became larger than
I thought it would be.
But in the perspective of
being on the top looking down,
it was something I felt. I
waited while until I felt
that zone like clarity, like
this is what we want to do
and I see it.
It's going to happen.
And here I go.
AUDIENCE: So in a
way, you've been
a pioneer of marrying
the sport and photography
that you did when you started.
So you've seen as far as some
sort of unexplored territory
that not a lot of
riders are looking into.
Like, in a way,
you are 25 or 30,
right, when you starting doing
this personal photography?
What is the creative,
unexplored territory today
that you would have done
if you had to be completely
creative [INAUDIBLE]?
MIKE BASICH: I think
the key element
to that is knowing less.
I was able to shoot
cameras in a way
because I didn't know
anything about them.
And so I kind of twisted
the rules a little bit
because I wasn't taught.
I just kind of took
it in a raw space.
And so I think it's important
to learn about things.
And what I've learned, if you're
going to learn about something
and want to be in a
new space with it,
creative-wise and
innovative-wise,
is to go back to
that discomfort,
crossing the threshold,
letting go of everything
you know, and just kind
of like take a risk
on putting something
together that
has a lot to do with
timing and where
technology is at the moment.
Because what's happened with me
is technology met some ideas.
Some took 10 years,
some took weeks.
But they all kind of
were a moment in time
that wasn't together yet.
And I look outside
of snowboarding
a lot, outside of photography a
lot, at different technologies.
The drone world-- soon as
I saw something happen,
I realized I don't need
a paraglider anymore.
I don't know how a camera's
going to mount on a drone yet,
because they're too heavy,
but four or five years later,
it finally happened.
And so that's kind
of in a simple way
of a different equation
from different industries
coming together to do
something together.
SPEAKER 1: I guess I have a
few more questions as well.
One of the questions
is where Google--
I work for YouTube.
I'm an engineer on YouTube.
What's going on with your
YouTube channel right now?
MIKE BASICH: Not much.
I, for some reason,
don't spend a lot of time
on my YouTube channel.
I don't know if it's because
I'm unfamiliar with it.
I probably blame some of that
on the edits that come out.
I've handed over the
footage to someone else
and they keep their edits
on their YouTube channels.
And so that's kind
of what I've learned
a little bit in my photography.
I've sat down and
edited my own things,
but I have more coverage, more
marketability if I hand it
over to somebody and they can
do something else with it.
And so I don't have a lot of
control over all the videos
to put on my
YouTube is one part.
SPEAKER 1: Do you edit all
of your own content as well?
MIKE BASICH: I do on some level.
I used to do it a lot, but
it's the quality, everything--
I'm on the road so much.
I can only do so
much with my laptop.
Everything else is too
much for me to handle,
so I usually just
hand things off
because I'm bouncing
around a lot.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
That's the easy way to do it.
What awesome technologies
are you kind of looking for,
that you've seen in
the news or you've
seen other companies
working on that you're
really excited about that
might influence your work?
MIKE BASICH: Oh, I'm not
totally pinpointed on,
like, the circle camera.
I've seen that get invaded
into a little ball now.
So I'm kind of curious on
where that perspective goes.
Sometimes I worry that it's
getting farther and farther
away from us
learning how to feel
the experience, that there's a
bigger gap in the actual action
part of the self doing it.
And so that's one thing that
when you look at a screen,
I get a little worried if
the kids watching this,
that they're going to
actually go and do it
or if that's just enough.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah
MIKE BASICH: Because we're--
technology-wise, it's
becoming more and more real,
like that you're actually there.
And that's making.
I think, the younger
generation just--
that's cool, that's it.
They don't have the
desire to go do it.
So I'm hoping somewhere
in the mix of technology
in days to come,
that it'll bring
us into a more of a
feeling it ourselves.
SPEAKER 1: Do you kind of look
at VR as an extension of that?
So it'll make kids
passive and accepting of,
oh, I did it in VR, so I don't
need to do it in real life.
MIKE BASICH: I-- no.
I don't.
What I do see it doing is being
a teaching-- if somebody wants
to learn how to do
a trick, I think
it could help them
visualize what
it is to do a double backflip.
So they get to see something.
But the simpleness of just,
say, snowboarding, just
going down a hill, I
think, does the opposite.
It brings a person farther
away from doing a sport.
And I've learned-- my niece
actually has scoliosis
and she's doing some
major exercises that
are very painful.
And the VR has
actually been very pain
relieving because it makes your
mind disconnect from your body
on some level because you're
in this other world, of course.
That's kind of the idea.
So I see a huge
outlet for people
to be released from
struggles or just
taking a break from life or
gain through a certain exercise
and getting progressive with.
SPEAKER 1: So what
happens if you
were to use VR when you're
living off the grid?
MIKE BASICH: Oh, I
had someone come out
and we filmed the full VR video.
And for me, it's a
little-- it's hard
because I'm there all the
time, then I watch something
and it's different.
You feel like you didn't get to
tell the whole story that you
wanted to tell.
And this has happened
in my whole career.
People take their own stories
on when they see a certain image
or video.
And the VR, I think, is it's
a three dimension, gives you
something back to
losing yourself,
which I think is a plus.
But too much, I wonder.
Like, it's less
being in the world.
In some ways, we're
creating a world.
So I kind of--
I don't know.
I challenge you on
where we're going
to go with that
because in some ways,
we're all responsible
for what happens.
Each generation is
born into groundwork.
And so the next
generation is going
to think VR is just the
standard, which it probably
will become a standard.
But no one's really, as
generation comes on, they never
ask, could we do it different?
They're just kind of
like, it's already set.
Progress with it,
but maybe there's
a moment where someone
should have said, no.
If you're going to
do this, you need
to at least go outside
and stick your hands
in the dirt for five minutes.
Just remember that you're here.
SPEAKER 1: Switching gears,
I wanted to ask about this.
So you didn't go
over this at all,
but you build your
own ski lift, right?
Like, on your property, out
in the middle of nowhere,
with your hands.
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
MIKE BASICH: Yeah.
That pushed my
engineering ability a lot.
Yeah I came across this
old chairlift from Sweden.
It was in pieces.
And I had a tow rope for
years at my property,
so I was like, oh, this is
perfect, to get off the ground
and bury anything.
And it wasn't so
much of something
I had a long-term goal of,
but I love progressing.
My mind is always busy so
I'm trying to find a place
to put it to action.
So this was something that
got me an understanding of how
the engineering of physics
work because I am not
very good at schooling.
I'm just great on
hand and back to I
was willing to take the risk of
whatever this was going to be.
And I learned a lot.
It's fascinating, engineering
of what happens on a chairlift.
300 pounds becomes 12,000
pounds within seconds.
SPEAKER 1: But you
were never worried
that you were going to fall off
or it was going to break or--
MIKE BASICH: Oh, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
MIKE BASICH: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: I guess the drop
was less than the 30 meters
from the helicopter.
MIKE BASICH: Yeah, it was
rocks, so it's a little harder.
But I had a bunch
of friends help out.
And some never came
back, some stuck
through the whole process.
Took about eight months.
And I didn't have
any fancy equipment,
so a lot of cowboy just putting
ropes up the trees with winches
because we lifted six towers.
And drawing a straight line
in mid air up the mountain
is pretty challenging to
figure out how to do that.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
MIKE BASICH: So it was fun
working with old school
equipment and
figuring that all out.
SPEAKER 1: I'm kind of curious
about your shopping habits.
This is weird
question, but so you
said you think a lot
about what you're
going to buy before you bring
it back home because there's
effort involved in both
bringing it there and taking
the rubbish away.
MIKE BASICH: Yeah, yeah.
I've learned paper--
I have fire as my hot
water heating source.
So anything I could
burn, I burn it.
I've learned the amount of
fuel to recycle certain things,
it's better just to burn it.
So I don't burn everything.
There's some things I come back
and recycle when I can in town,
but it's a lot
[INAUDIBLE] due to weight.
Sometimes I'm hiking,
the whole hike up I
have a snowmobile or a snowcat.
Depending on the
snow conditions I
can drive a snowcat to my door.
I mean, it takes a half hour.
But if I don't have that
option, which the weather always
kind of predicts whether
I can do that or not.
So I try just to plan like,
kind of like you're camping
in some form, efficient, smart.
Don't over-shop
for wasting stuff.
SPEAKER 1: So sustainability
is a big aspect
of most of your shopping trips.
MIKE BASICH: Yeah, yeah.
And it's also
vegetables last longer
and meat in certain
temperatures.
I'm like, OK, I'm a vegetarian
for the next four months.
Yeah, so I try to move around.
And I travel a
lot, so I'm moving.
I'm trying to be OK
with the traveling, too.
It's like back to knowing more.
It's hard to figure out
where to place yourself.
I'm learning as we go and trying
to be with you all with that.
SPEAKER 1: That's cool.
If anybody else those
questions, always feel free.
SPEAKER 2: We have
questions on the Dory.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, there's a Dory.
SPEAKER 2: Is there
any possible shot
that was actually
impossible and was given up.
If so, any plans
to get that sooner
with better technology now?
MIKE BASICH: Oh, to
do something better.
I must say my brain
has slowed down
after so many years of
taking self portraits.
But there's Follow Cam.
I love working with
pilots for drone pilots.
And one of the fascinating
parts about drones--
is I guess it's not exactly
about the photography part,
but I can put on VR goggles and
I can watch the drone go down
my line, say, in Alaska
because a lot of time,
you can't see what you're
going down, it's so steep.
And there might
be three chutes--
two of them cliff out, the other
one you're supposed to go down.
But it all looks different
when you get to the top.
And so I feel like that
would advance photography
and the athlete because
they're more confident,
they can perform
better, and you'll
end up with something
more technical as a shot,
which can bring more beauty
or new space to work with.
SPEAKER 1: So not only advances
to take the shot, but just
your ability to go
down the mountain.
MIKE BASICH: Yeah.
Yeah.
I mean, I would love to be able
to make a drone go away from me
and come back as I'm
moving down the mountain,
if I can be that
close to something.
So far, I just know
one pilot that's
willing to do it with me.
But it's the part of
that's kind of what happens
when you're snowboarding.
You're very in your
space, but then you're
also going back to looking
100 feet ahead of you.
So your mind's going in and out
of your body in some ways, just
to be aware.
And so if you can make a
camera do that, that's--
I feel that would be
another space to work with.
SPEAKER 1: What was your
most terrifying line
that you've ran?
MIKE BASICH: There's one,
actually, it was a remote
and the hill slid.
And I remember being on
top of a double cliff.
And I went off the first cliff.
It was in an avalanche
and I couldn't see,
but I remember
halfway in the air,
like, if I stay
in this position,
I'm going to land on
my back on the rock.
That was my most odds.
And last second,
I rotated as much
as I could and I hit
my hip on the rock
instead of directly in the back.
Put me out for months.
But that was kind of
my scariest moment,
like the moment of thinking
that something's going
to happen to me permanently.
The heaviness got a quick
response or the best I could.
SPEAKER 1: Spider sense.
Do we have anything
else on the Dory?
Sorry.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah.
One more, actually.
Also from [INAUDIBLE],,
you have a big fan here.
What do you think about
those full-time Instagram
snowboarders?
Here's an example--
Jerome [INAUDIBLE] Snowboarding.
There's a YouTube
link, but I don't think
we can play it in the--
so it's basically,
what do you think
about those full-time
Instagram snowboarders?
MIKE BASICH: I think--
SPEAKER 2: I have more details.
MIKE BASICH: Yeah, yeah.
Well, I'll grab
onto some ideas here
of what I've learned
in snowboarding,
say, on the athlete side is
snowboarding progressed so much
with what people are doing in
competitions and in the latest
videos that it's so much that
the consumer actually doesn't
want to be the person anymore.
It looks too hard.
It looks out of reach.
And so what I've learned
sharing more of a lifestyle,
whatever that is.
Mine's off the grid.
People feel more
connected. it just feels
more real backyard feeling.
And so I feel like
there's a more marketing
tool within that.
And in snowboarding, it
hasn't always been there.
It's been actually very
challenging to beat
the 18-year-old out of the
seat to be in the market seat.
But I feel like that's actually
what's naturally happening now,
just people are--
they watch the Olympics
and it's cool to watch.
It's awesome.
But a lot of people like, no.
I just want to go have fun.
And that's kind of
the basics of why
a lot of us got
into snowboarding
was just for pure fun.
And there's the competitive
side and it's progressed a lot,
but the heart of
just pure fun is,
I think, the main
seat of snowboarding.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
I agree with that.
We're going to hear
the music soon.
So anyways, I want to thank you
for coming and talking with us
today.
It's been awesome to hear
your life and experiences.
MIKE BASICH: Thanks
for having me.
Thank you for your time.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]